yeah hello with pins welcome to the
video playing age sacrifices okay Egypt
and you don't see less a single and
language you don't see that it's just
too small so each of track is difficult
for me to identify so anyways we have
our probably reti opening how before
yeah that's a rare move what is he
playing if I go queen to be three back
on you should see it or something tricky
like ninety six or so what I don't quite
see that this would work oh that's a
creative food creative reply interesting
okay so I don't want them to after d3
damage my structure after move for we
reached a position that was never seen
in the whole history of chess I said
probably very funny okay so he tried to
wants to go to see 6am with the bishop
so I'm waiting a bit III
Jim I know please he might take it but
my development is pretty good so I
wonder like DTX fts and then play for
development very unconventional position
[Music]
I really not sure what is the what is
supposed to do develop the drives this
is a bit if he takes I can actually take
with the Queen that that could be
interesting as well because it's a
temple Wow
one in the decks fantastically ambitious
move pulling the pawn down very hard to
believe but you can in order to refute
that after I have to put some pressure
on this poor many do the same
immediately I don't see how he keeps it
please I think is the Polish just gone
however after taking I'm going to have a
somewhat questionable structure I mean
structure is wrong with is the set up
the piece set up is a little bit a
little bit off please 95 I go cleanly
five and so whether this is also
dropping the porn on be 7 plus the d5
square ok for the wall I'm taking this
and now go for here how to play the same
the pony is not yet doing all that much
I need to get development on maybe this
light have to go from here
I want to get d3 and simply I think you
should have prevented Bishop g5 now I'm
getting produced fantastic knight on d5
of course he will have the knight c6
idea also but I think it doesn't matter
all that much ready to change the snyder
of course of course I'm happy to do that
maybe he takes with the book yeah going
into full-scale sizzling mode so i need
to get get rid of the night right f5 it
will take that anyway
one thing I don't really need that
exchange I mean I'm totally fine with
giving up giving the exchange back i
also have an extra pawn the Queen will
be fantastic on your form so that [ __ ]
coming I don't know come rain it doesn't
hurt so what is he trying to do i will
go F for Queen only four is just very
well placed and you will have to take
this I'm covering the diagonal i'm
covering h7 so there is no is very
little and turn the swindling chance to
see i think through g8 a google f8 look
fh mate and king g8 i go 25 check check
okay black resign okay so that and it
was an extremely ambitious opening
player black let's see him yet d4
already looks a bit shaky the
combination of default d4 and the bishop
es is really weird a little bit because
in the bishop is not essential on f5
it's not necessary piece and if you play
d4 you need some support for the pawn
and I don't know if you get that him
Bishop g2 is maybe even stronger as
suggested by the comp having all kinds
of ideas let's see six beef lamb that's
also funny all right and I don't really
believe in the leg set up we should be
fun ok and then III I need to open it up
an interesting question is what I do if
he takes I wasn't really not sure about
it the engine wants to take with the
deep on and then I did not see as so
critical but maybe the opening of the
default is really really great computer
only 150 interesting and 93 rookie one
gaining more time yeah it looks good it
looks good I was starting out with this
move liking it and this is cannot be bad
but then at the end have thought that
this might be interesting this has one
point also winning 10 winning time I
think here let's is free and then d for
this kind of thing or locally one I
don't know it sounds good to me but
maybe this is not dead fantastic
actually interesting
okay d3n it that I cannot believe I'm
just winning material I could have
traded on b7 a couple of times maybe
without being a punished for it but at
the end this is a good way out from
keeping control yeah now I'm ready to
challenge this with 92 one night at five
yeah okay well it's it's just the big
thing is my biz not only five is just
stronger than its bishop and I'm getting
the e4 square so this is just nice yeah
Queen III wasn't necessary I'm returning
the exchange service it's just the
disposition is just winning now nothing
more nothing less if he trades and takes
illnesses when why does a pawn up and I
have so much better minor piece then I
think f4 is a good idea it just opens up
and trades down to winning ending yeah
this was probably just a bit of her too
ambitious opening set up a black ok guys
thanks for watching